Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P This is another voicemail
about me texting people. Just a reminder,
these are scams. I'm not texting anybody.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I got one of your texting.
Call me direct message right away. But no,
I don't have the Internet. I don't have
a computer. I got off that damn vitriolic
Internet platform stuff four years ago.
Speaker 1: Well, good for you.
Speaker 3: I do listen to your show and more and
I'll read the stuff that comes up on. YouTube.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, listen, this. This. I feel
bad for this guy. There are people on YouTube,
and because there's hundreds and hundreds, we
report them as quickly as we can. Okay. But they
keep popping up. They put my face in their profile
picture and then they respond to YouTube comment
to go, hey, love the comment. Could you text me or
WhatsApp me or DM me or whatever the case may be?
I love everybody, but I am not trying to text
any of you. These are scams. They will try to
steal your money. Okay. Report them to YouTube for
impersonation. We report them as well. I feel bad.
It's weird. I'm not. I'm too busy to text with
people. Okay. I'm not even texting my friends
back because I'm so busy. I'm not trolling my own
YouTube comments looking for people to text. So it
is not me. At some point there will be a scam at
the end of the rainbow. At some point they'll try
to take money from you or something. I don't even
really know what the scammers. On the bonus show
today, folks. Very good news. Brittney Griner
has been released by Russia. This was a one
for one prisoner swap for arms dealer Viktor Bout.
There are people saying this was not a fair trade,
that this was crazy to release Viktor Bout. Okay,
we will talk about it. Secondly, we're going to
talk about the Indonesian sex ban. What does that
mean and what does it mean for producer Pat who
will join me on the bonus show? And thirdly, we're
going to talk about the real reason that Iran says
it's canceling the morality police. What? Yes.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Sign up at. Join Pacman dot com.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Beautifully set. I'll
see you on the bonus show. Back to.